Emily Blunt you are one of fandango's
most favorite people to talk to I'm
speaking for the whole offense yes one
of my favorite I'm glad I'm looking at
your filmography you have done so many
incredible roles so we thought we would
celebrate your career by playing a game
of name that moming oh cool I'm gonna be
doing a terrible line reading of one of
your quotes from one of your movies
then you're gonna guess which movements
from are you ready yes here we go
you have to die every day keep coming
here and I'll train you edge' to work
thing I'm gonna tell everyone what you
did The Devil Wears Prada
I know Sicario yes
oh if life were made of moments even now
and then a bad one but if life were made
of moments then you'd never know you had
one you're gonna have to sing it
otherwise people don't know it's from
internal one yeah I don't know what's
that you just say sorry for what you did
say sorry but who you are the girl on
the train yeah in cinemas October 7
that's round one
okay I'm gonna up the difficulty factor
okay now I'm gonna give you a quote and
one of your leading men o ta a crossbow
doesn't clean itself you know when did I
lose a use a crossbow clue very funny
guy also starred in a movie with puppets
Oh Jason Segel um five your engagement
of course I get shot with a crossbow how
would I forget that it's all become a
blur alright everyone good your loins
stanley tucci I love that little devil
where's brother my face always annoys
you Oh
mark Duplass in Sister sisters and that
is it how did I do when my blunt you won
I'm Dana thank you well thank God thank
you so much for playing
in that movie and yeah Roubaix and make
sure you go and see the girl on the
train out October 7th thank you so much
thank you
[Music]
you